beruf habe ich als bank drücker meine
damen und herren das ist jude
hier sind es bereits im titel
eingebettet und ihr seht es auch schon
hier eingebildet meine damen und herren
das antriebsrad und was sie außerdem
schon dem titel eingeblendet ist dass
wir heute eine stadt land fluss
challenge machen jedes kind sollte
eigentlich stadt land fluss kennen dann
geht es dann auf die stadt los geht es
darum dass man sich ein buch stach
heraus sucht und mit diesem buchstaben
einen es geht darum dass man sich einen
buchstaben haus sucht und dieser punkt
starke muss man der anfangsbuchstabe von
den vorher definierten kategorien sein
wir haben heute die kategorien stadland
youtuber beruf gegenstand den man auf
eine einsame insel mitnehmen würde
wir haben in unserer stadt land fluss
game allerdings ein wenig abgespeckt auf
neues level gehoben
wir haben wir nämlich noch ein glückstag
am start das heißt sie werden
abwechselnd dieses stücks batterien
haben ich glaube diese scheiße hier mit
den buchstaben a das heißen würden nun
beide anfangen auch unser blatt papier
diese fünf kategorien die ich euch
vorhin gezeigt habe mal abzuarbeiten und
wer als erstes zu jedem der fünf
kategorien ein wort mit den
anfangsbuchstaben a aufgestiegen hat der
ruft stock und trägt dann seine sachen
vor wenn die schule jetzt beispielsweise
die stadt hätte und würde als erster
stopp rufen und ich hätte dann auch
machen dann würde jude den punkt
bekommen weil jude zuerst aachen auf
geschrieben hätte hätte ich dann
allerdings die stadt erschaffen wurde
wenn wir beide 1 punkt bekommen weil ich
eine andere stadt habe ich hoffe ihr
habt die regel verstanden und wir fangen
jetzt an jennifers meine damen und
herren der buchstabe n ok los geht's als
er ist eine stadt mit
[Musik]
ja okay jetzt also ich habe als erster
stopp gesagt deswegen jule stadt habe
ich nürnberg ok krieg ich den pongau
lang habe ich nigeria okay wir beide
punkte mit in unser nachbarland youtube
nebel nick beruf habe ich nutze ich habe
nur note sehr gut und einsame insel habe
ich nur teller im nagel ist
wenn im bild dann sagen okay ich will
nicht so sein dann kriegst du den punkt
für für nagel schreibt in die kommentare
was ist sinnvoller nagel oder unterricht
reden meine damen und herren und der
buchstabe für diese runde ist stoppt ich
habe also als kreisstadt habe ich
erschaffen burg ok kriege beiden land
habe mich afrika darin erkläre ich mir
sage ich ihnen beide kleinen punkt
youtuber habe ich aha so der macht
minecraft und so hast du kein recht wenn
ich wirklich keine user berichten aber
vielleicht wenn ihr im zweiten teil
wollte kamen julia die kategorien
bestimmen oder ihr könnt uns wenn ihr
wollt kategorien bauen in die kommentare
schreiben für einen zweiten teil beruf
habe ich
[Musik]
und einsame insel habe ich arznei
wirklich angel ok ja macht beides sind
aber arzneimittel macht mehr sinn ein
dorf dessen foto krank werden kann
dritte sind meine lieben freunde der
buchstabe c ich denke halt auch daran
dass ich nicht irgendwas nehmen dass du
vielleicht haben können dass damit wenn
du zuerst die schreibt weiter dass jetzt
nicht mehr unter druck als alle
fußballturniere meiner kindheit bisschen
spät aber heftig ich krieg dich mal für
jedes worten punkt sagen jetzt habe ich
tübingen jura hat thüringen wächst zwar
wechselt also und dem punkt gegen
tübingen beim land hast du
hundertprozentig zu
ich habe den punkt okay kratzt sich am
extra in puncto genommen weil ich dachte
dass du keinem spa beauty series hättest
du auch drauf kommen können
das ist gerade der kampf rechte
inzwischen privatisierten typ et 10
millionen saps im monat ist ein
indischer musik kanal der gerade dabei
ist die größte kanal der welt zu werden
beruf habe ich tierarzt ok krieg ich
habe den punkt bei stopp gesagt hat und
einsame insel habe ich 1000 anzug ich
habe okay dass beides gut aber kriegen
wir beide punkt das heißt ich habe
täglich fünf punkte gerade gemacht
wahrscheinlich sind deine eltern sollten
also ich drehe freunde die vierte runde
vergiss nicht in buchstaben w ich denke
wieder so richtig bescheuert gerade weil
ich will dass du als erster stopsack ein
paar sekunden später land stehe ich
komplett auf dem schlauch
[Musik]
also ich fotografiere wieder fünf punkte
stand habe ich geschaut hätte ich auch
gedacht dass du willst bislang habe ich
weiß russland
also ich hab auch die ganze zeit
überlegt wer ist kein land mit w
eingefallen youtube wissenswert also ich
kenne auch wissen es werden nur weil ich
auch videos von diemer von denen man
reagiert der beruf habe ich
wissenschaftler
ich hab das ja die wartungsarbeiter
kriegs auch einsame insel habe ich
weiter
es war und ist ähnlich hatte auch gesagt
hey du kannst google und den über
bestellen
diese entwicklung ist ja okay dann
kriegst nur zu dem punkt hängt man
praktisch denn der insel bestätigte kein
wlan ab vorletzte runde meine damen und
herren den stab oder das glück immer
noch top los geht's ich glaube das
können wir unter seinen titelgewinn
youtuber überlege ich halt immer wahr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
geworden ich da hab ich liegen
aber ich habe schon mit land habe ich
weiß ich habe schweben trotzdem wird das
thema ich hab das auch schwer waren die
lose ich habe gar nichts ich dachte er
ich wollte erst riss tivi aufschreiben
aber das wäre nicht die youtuber gewesen
ich habe so die klinik angestellt habe
ich glaube nicht dass das ist gegenstand
für eine insolvenz erst schlafsack
gewechselt ich hab einen
seelenverwandten tödtmann irland wenn
die wirklich okay meine damen und herren
die letzte runde steht an erstmal schon
mal sorry das gewicht fällt müssen hier
ein bisschen in sich geändert haben aber
es ist schlagartig irgendwie die welt
untergegangen der letzte buchstabe für
die letzte runde stadt land fluss jahre
meine damen und herren
okay ich habe gehört dass der langston
geschrieben das hat sich doch ist es
recklinghausen und ich schreibe etwas
andere finden
[Musik]
nein im ernst ich habe über mund
genommen extra für das tracking
ausgenommen waren lange wurst lernen ich
habe keins ich da war ich gerade am
schreiben und ich habe rieter oder da
gibst du mir roma-frauen youtube-kanal
räte auch motorblocks keine ahnung ob
blogs aber im winter musikus ist auch in
youtuber romantiker ja ok dagegen stand
für die einzelnen sämtlichen regen
stellen sich in die verlegung zu
schützen
ich habe so meine damen und herren es
ist vorbei wir haben sechs runden stadt
land fluss mit dem glücksrad gespielt
jede runde hatte fünf kategorien das
heißt zum höchsten hätte man fünf punkte
kriegen können und im schlechtesten fall
halt 0
ich habe extra keine punktzahl während
des videos eingeblendet damit es jetzt
eine art überraschungsmoment ist als
jude und ich ziehe jetzt zusammen unsere
punkte durch
120 nein du hast ihre genommen ich
wusste aber und punkt haben also meine
damen und herren unglück von schüler auf
jeden fall an der stelle dass wir das
ganze besonders die bestrafung der zeit
dass ich mit dieser brille ein bild in
meiner entscheidung story posten muss
instagram gekommen luca heute ist in der
story um eine bestrafung ist damit
beendet
mit dem volt dass wir das ganze noch mal
machen dann lasst einen daumen hoch bei
diesem video da schreibt im stern andere
kategorien und in die kommentare und
anderen staaten die wir auch jeden tag
drauf schreiben sollen weil wir hatten
ja jetzt gerade mal 14 starben
und von denen sind auch nur sechs
drangekommen es euch gefallen hat die
gesagt abonniert gerne einen kanal
klickt auf abonnieren gibt einen daumen
runter bei julius instagram bildern
[Musik]
zum 1